das ist die wohl größte
modelleisenbahnanlage der welt mehr als
500 züge der spur geht rollen in den
modellbau welten bispingen über die
gleise
das schienennetz ist insgesamt 20
kilometer lang
die anlage selbst steht unter einer auf
stelzen gebauten skihalle im
norddeutschen becken also letztendlich
ist es ja so dass wir immer noch 12.000
quadratmeter 7000 quadratmeter baufläche
haben das ist mit abstand das größte was
es weltweit gibt in dem maßstab und auch
von maschinen länge und wir haben auch
bücher von den themen her fast weltweit
alles zusammen insgesamt sind das 50
themenwelten wir sind einmal links sowie
in sölden österreich vorne weil der weg
über die alpen des von bayern auf der
rechten seite haben wir lebten zwischen
tansania afrika und der italien konnte
grenzen
[Musik]
rückblick im februar dieses jahres läuft
der aufbau der xxl anlage noch auf
hochtouren
ein team aus tischlern und dekorateuren
baut landschaften ins holz kunststoff
und mörtel mit dabei jogi meiners der
kreative leiter des projekts auch in den
werkstätten wird gesägt geschraubt
geklebt und gemalt werkstätten und hier
bauen wir häuser für alle verschiedenen
themenbereiche südamerika afrika alles
mögliche und hier werden halt dann die
häuser brücken kleine figuren alles
mögliche gemacht und dann halt draußen
eingebaut
bis die anlage fertig ist dauert es
insgesamt 16 monate hinter den kulissen
kümmert sich volker hansen um die 500
züge und deren wartung bei einem maßstab
von 1 zu 22,5 können die lokomotiven
über einen meter lang sein
sein favorit ein modell von 1941 das ist
eine der größten wenn manchmal schon
dampflokomotiven sogenannte big boi die
hierzu restauriert worden ist und wir
haben noch ein modell davon ergattern
können das zurzeit auch nicht mehr
hergestellt wird ist aus voll metall und
wiegt 53 kilogramm und da habe ich schon
schwierigkeiten nur ein hotel wirklich
auf die gleise zu setzen was macht man
am besten zu zweit
um bei einer anlage dieser größe nicht
den überblick zu verlieren sind alle
zugfahrten programmiert und zentral
koordiniert das ist so genannte
leitstand über denen die komplette
modell eisenbahn gesteuert wird die
anlage ist ja digital gesteuert und wird
über computer über rechner gefahren das
heißt also über eine software
wir haben hier 14 computer eingebaut wo
jedes anlagenteil entsprechen also
gesteuert wird also fahrzeuge aufrufen
werden können und das controlling von
hier stellt besucher und modelleisenbahn
fans erwartet hier eine weltreise auf
schienen von südtirol mit schroffen
bergen ist es nur ein katzensprung bis
zur freiheitsstatue das kommt an bord
spannenden ort zu schauen was ist dann
ist und doch macht einen guten eindruck
mit dieser modelleisenbahnanlage im
xxl-format hoffen die betreiber nun auf
einen eintrag in das guinness-buch der
beklaute
[Musik]